you look like a tough guy you look like
an intimidating tough guy were you an
athlete growing up an athlete
no not even sort of an athlete growing
up I was uh just a funny kid which kind
of got you know I guess in basketball I
could do okay I was tall right they
tried to get me to wrestle but I saw
that uniform and I'm I'm insecure enough
you know what the coach actually told me
he goes it'd be great you'll be in the
super heavy weights there's no one to
wrestle you just show up and win I was
too fast I have an opponent that's good
for your self-esteem yeah I know I had a
rough go in school in fact the one time
I there was a girl that I liked in
school I remember growing up that I
would cut school with her a lot and go
to her house but I think I had more
higher hopes for was gonna happen than
she was just cutting school with some
somebody and as I would leave her house
every day to go home after cutting
school there people started asking me if
if we were hooking up you know you're
cutting school every day are you guys
hooking up and I said uh I didn't know
what I was embarrassed so I went what do
you guys think I mean I go there all the
time right
and I'm sure that happens daily hundreds
of times in every school all around the
country Sheriff and generally what
happens you know you get called on it
you get called an idiot you may have to
apologize to someone or or whatever not
me what happened was a guy another guy
who liked her said I like you but I
don't want to muscle it I know you've
been sleeping with Jay oakerson
and she found that out and instead of
just taking this to like a calling
you're getting upset her family called
my family to say they were pressing
charges
what for slander and defamation of
character which also as a kid talk about
hurting yourself esteem is it defamation
of character to say you would sleep with
me
like I just see calling me for lying
yeah sure defamation of how would you
say a gross thing like that would ever
happen yeah
so it became a big deal like I called me
the principal's office with my mother
and who I thought was cool because the
principal said he goes well listen
you're gonna have to make a public
apology really a public apology an
assembly or we're gonna expel you and I
looked at my mom with the sense of I was
just like obviously like I guess we're
just picking up moving on mom huh like
all in the next city you started packing
your bag I'm like you know I knew this
day would come with that stick in the
bandanna oh my god it's why I pack light
and she was like no of course of course
you're gonna do this apology and she she
made me do it and we're again as other
kids might just be slightly embarrassed
and have to deal with repercussions from
their friends and Ally like this I find
myself with my grandmother shopping for
a husky suit to do a public apology was
it like in the school auditorium I mean
where was this yeah I had to walk out
there I think the first funny thing I
ever said on stage was as many of you
probably guessed when I said it I never
actually slept with said girl did you
got a laugh I've got a big laugh never
dumb to believe in the first place yeah
then you're like you know what I like
this business convene this could be a
living
you